COMMITTEE IS CALLED THE ORDER
PLEASE BE ADVISED THAT AN AUDIO
AND VIDEO RECORDINGS BEING MADE
OF TODAY'S PROCEEDINGS IT'S
ALSO BEING TELEVISED SECRETARY
WOULD YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
COOLEY CUNNINGHAM HERE SENATE
FLORA IF GIPSON LI LEVINE.
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS RAMOS RUBIO
HERE WHO ARE HERE NO CAR. WE
HAVE QUORUM WE ALSO HAVE
CONSENT ARE MOTION ON THE
CONSENT AGENDA. MOVEMENT IS
RUBIO SECOND. YES SECOND. WHO
WAS A ROBUST SECTION MISTER
FROM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. COOLEY CUNNINGHAM HI
CUNNINGHAM I BET FLOOR. FLORA I
KEPT LEVY LEVINE LEVINE HI MAY.
MAIENSCHEIN I'M FROM. RAMOS
RAMOS I- RUBIO. RUBIO HIVE YOUR
FOOD WILL THE FOOD WHILE I
GIPSON HI GIPSON HI MOTION
PASSES THE MOTION PASSED I WILL
THE ROLE OPEN FOR MEMBERS ADD
ON. INTEL. AND TELL I WISH NOW.
UNTIL FIVE OF NINE ABOUT THE
WORK. IN ORDER.
ONE FIVE- HOW
AT THAT. BENNETT HIGH. WELL.
YEAH YEAH. ON. YEAH. YEAH. YEAH.
YEAH. MICROPHONE. FINAL. ALL.
ONE YEAH. UHHUH NUMBER. ONLINE.
THE PROBLEM. WILL BE. FORTY I
DON'T LEGISLATIVE. GOOD. FOR
BUT WE NEED A BILLION DOLLAR
REMODEL SO THAT WE CAN ADD
LEGISLATORS. YEAH WE ARE MOVING.
IF YOU'RE ON THE PHONE FOR
SESSION.